Будівельні крани та риштування - сьогодні це такий же
символ Берліна, як і знаменита East Side Gallery.
Це найдовший збережений фрагмент Берлінської стіни,
який митці з цілого світу перетворили
на картинну галерею просто неба.
Між галереєю та річкою Шпрее
утворився величезний пустир,
вартість якого оцінюється в сотні мільйонів євро.
Це чи не найбільша досі незабудована ділянка
на березі річки і ласий шматок для інвесторів.
Ця біла вежа з елітними апартаментами - перший
будпроект в безпосередній близькості від галереї.
І - останній, як сподіваються активісти
з об'єднання  "Монумент радості".
Наша мета полягає в тому, що East Side Gallery
повинна надихати людей на боротьбу за мир, свободу
і взаєморозуміння між народами.
Мир - це не подарунок, за нього потрібно боротися,
тому ми й хочемо, щоб тут був живий монумент радості.
А оскільки галерея виникла як проект стріт-арт,
основний акцент нашої роботи - мистецтво,
яке говорить метафорами, а це -
ідеальна платформа для нього.
Активісти кажуть, що хочуть зупинити заплановане будівництво
і зберегти відкритий простір на березі річки.
Якщо подивитися на правий і лівий берег Шпрее,
то видно, що майже всі земельні ділянки розпродані
і що галерея - останнє місце, де уздовж понад одного
кілометра ще є вільне для забудови місце.
Якщо ми як громадяни цього міста об'єднаємося і
станемо на захист цієї пам'ятки миру, свободи
і радості, то у нас все вийде. У всякому разі,
ми вже отримуємо перші сигнали про це. Тож дуже важливо
висловлювати свою думку, щоби впливати на ситуацію.
Чотири роки тому протести на захист East Side Gallery
привернули увагу в світі - петицію на захист галереї
підписали понад 100 тисяч осіб.
Відтоді ціни на земельні ділянки тут зросли вшестеро.
З нагоди чергової річниці падіння Берлінського муру
активісти  розпочинають ще один збір підписів.
Особисто для мене це важливо, тому що це
пам'ятник дружбі народів, миру і свободі. І я вважаю,
що він повинен бути збережений і для наступних поколінь.
Тому я підтримую ініціативу.
Ми хочемо, щоб тут був живий меморіал, бо часи
змінюються, і з'являються актуальні теми, які можна
осмислювати за допомогою мистецтва. І ось цей простір
за моєю спиною - ідеальне місце для арт-інсталяцій
митців з усього світу.
Тим часом берлінське відділення Партії Зелених
закликало мерію подати заявку в ЮНЕСКО
на внесення East Side Gallery до списку
Всесвітньої культурної спадщини.
Щоправда, за оцінками експертів, шанси на успіх невеликі.